i want to start with a huge thank you i
spent yesterday binging the series i was
tackling like a i mean the people next
door must have thought i was crazy just
from my laughing uh i just
i want to thank you for making me laugh
like a hysterical person leslie steve we
just the whole goal of this was to not
let people like yourselves down so if we
if we did if we did that
that was our entire goal
i i'm going to say you uh mission
mission accomplished um i want to start
i want to start this interview off by
giving a huge thank you to peacock for
letting you guys make this series and
for letting the gruber live again so
they just want to get that out there and
just say thank you to them that's
technically our job to but i thank you
thank you for thanking them
as a fan i just want to thank them you
know um so i want to start with the most
important question i think which is that
for people that don't realize
christopher nolan is a huge fan of
mcgruber and um so for both of you what
is it like finding out that he's like a
super fan and was quoting lines on like
the set of the last dark knight movie we
we found that out from our friend who
worked on i think it was jimmy fallon
where anne hathaway revealed that and
was like oh i always knew things were
going well on batman when christopher
nolan would start quoting mcgruber and
we were like what
so then i like i first like interacted
with him at a dj dinner because my wife
and i like my wife is a much more
talented director than i am and we were
at this features dinner and like and uh
and
she was like chris ronald's over there
you gotta go talk to him and so like i
went up and i was like hey chris uh you
know i'm you're my director this movie
mcgregor and he's like oh hey man and i
was like yeah what do you think about
this idea we're gonna make a sequel and
when it says directed by uh i wanted to
just say christopher nolan with an
asterisk and then at the end of the
movie there's another asterisk and it
says it's not christopher nolan he's
like ah i'll talk to my wife
but we were relentless in pursuing him
like he sent a super sweet note he
couldn't come to the table read
something but we invited him to the
table read i honestly have been
too up his butt about what i wanted to
see if he could get his throat ripped
out didn't have any time to that we
offered him any episode that he wanted
to direct
like i i think he's gotten to a point
where he's like well i'm not gonna
actually be a part of your world but i
do appreciate it right
john what's your reaction when he does
all this
i mean i i still don't quite believe it
right right but
i'll believe it when i see it i can't
yeah season two like chris i mean let's
[ __ ] rip some throats out
uh a hundred percent hopefully this
interview will lead to that um that's
what we're going for we're just trying
to peer pressure him via the press
uh i wanna something else i wanna talk
about for fans that are watching this uh
this is definitely a hard r in terms of
the the show did you get any pushback
from peacock at all at the throat rips
or the level of violence nope
no
i mean you're right it's very violent
yeah
yeah it doesn't shy away from anything
which of course i love you know um okay
so another thing i
will is one of the writers one of the
he's the guy right
yet he is so effing fearless like i
don't think anyone else would write so
many lines of you know magruber is naked
you know um like it's every episode he's
just taking clothes off what is it like
working with will when he's so committed
to this role
i would say i'll answer uh
like the
i would say it would be impossible it
would be impossible to make this if will
wasn't so unbelievably sharp with it's
not just it's like 150 percent with
every every single time he's on camera
but he like in terms of a person knowing
his lines and
and this was a difficult shoot we shot
this in 50 days and and it's a lot to do
in that amount of time and so there
would be moments where we're shooting
like an indie film where you get two
takes and if he's not [ __ ] nailing it
then it doesn't the scene doesn't work
and so we have actors like like will
like kristen who are just like if they
are pushed and they only get two takes
they're going to bring it in a way that
you're like i we wouldn't be able to do
the series without without such
unbelievable professionals which
wouldn't work and and i would say the
only time will is fearless and the only
time i've seen him waver a little tiny
bit at all and he he earned it he earned
it was
during the movie
uh after we were while we were shooting
the celery scene
probably toward the end of the celery
scene will will's mom and her friend
were there watching filming and a number
you know obviously but a big film crew
around at the after a few takes will was
like okay i think we i think we got
enough i think we got enough of this
can i say one more thing because i've
never seen this happen and this happened
on the filming the series and i haven't
mentioned this
i've never seen will break ever like
like all of snl i've never seen him
break and this was the first time i've
seen will break and and don't mention
this when you say like of what it is but
in episode 107
there's a little he does a little fart
and he and he raises his butt and
there's a like little breathless
fart that happens and that was that was
the thing that broke will and i couldn't
believe how stupid it was i was like
that's the thing that you're gonna laugh
at like holy [ __ ]
um how did you guys come up with the
eight episodes was it peacock's number
was it your number um or did they sort
of say like here's a budget and whatever
episodes you want to do you can do with
this amount of money well john talk
about talk about uh last man because you
guys how many episodes were guys doing
last night we
you know we started with i believe 13
then we went up to 18
episodes some something in that range um
i i think we
knowing how much work it was gonna be i
think we were hovering in around the
eight to ten episode range and then i i
think it just worked out that that made
sense for for peacock last man seeing
these guys in last minute it's just it's
so brutal you're always trying to catch
up to yourself and we had really really
wanted like for the amount of money we
were given i mean like all respected to
peacock because oh my god i can't
believe that they allowed us to do the
show in the slightest but you know like
it was going to be a tight schedule
always and so we really needed it to be
a tightly written script it's basically
a long movie broken up into eight parts
and so we really wanted like the story
to be as tight as it could because we
were going to crossboard it because like
basically me and john are on set every
day
some days like he has five scenes i have
two like then it flips the next day then
he has like a four days where it's
mostly him and like like but we're
shooting it like a cross-boarded movie
because it was the only way we could get
so much is like to shoot out locations
and blah blah so we kind of had to be
very very precise
um with this and we and we love it
feeling like it's more of a movie than
it is a tv show
oh and i mean all eight episodes it's
interconnected uh 100 the did you guys
ever debate calling it something but
mcgruber like mcgruber the series or
like something to distinguish the title
uh
the sequel at one point was gonna be
called mcgregor dick infested waters um
but
how does that answer your question no uh
no not for me i mean there was a joke at
one point where we were at one point in
the movie we were going to
mention that his dad reveals there was a
scene with his dad in the movie where he
reveals that his name's actually
magruder and it was a mistake on his
birth certificate and so at the end of
the movie it was going to say magruder
um so there was that joke that didn't
make it in and at this point i think
we'd probably want to bail on that kind
of hijinks
uh with peacock how much did they ask
you when you pitched them on doing the
series how much did they say do you guys
have like a three-year plan if you if
this is successful and do you know what
i mean or was it sort of like yeah just
do these episodes and let's see what
happens i think it was more of that yeah
but now tell them how many tell them how
many episodes they actually want seven
seasons they've just approved seven
seasons they love it
and they're going to up the budget they
said with every season we get an extra
10 million dollars because they just
were like more more yeah and then and
then they and and then in the meeting
they did a bunch of blow right after
that we're like
i'm [ __ ]
i'm almost out of time but i have to ask
you guys i think that the beginning of
episode one with maya's song and and
sort of catching everyone up if you you
know if you haven't if you haven't seen
the movie in a while or you forget uh is
so good can you sort of talk about uh
figuring out how to sort of catch
everyone up and getting maya to do that
that was that was all well forte uh
promoting that idea i think that comes
from snl honestly that kind of
that kind of thinking where you're like
how do you get people in the right frame
of mind to
you know it's like it is it is a little
scary of literally you're just dropping
people into this world of like you know
this character we all know and love this
character like well some people might
not and they might not know this so like
but i do think that like once you get
that little preamble the rest of the
show is very easy to to watch and follow
for even if you haven't seen the movie
oh a hundred percent um i already got a
rap i'm just gonna say seriously guys uh
great job and again thank you for making
me laugh so [ __ ] hard last night i
really appreciate it
and by the way we gotta do that that
screening of
yeah for people that don't realize who
are watching this we had sold out the
arclight hollywood for a thousand people
and we were gonna do mcgruber and we had
a very cool night planned and then kovid
said [ __ ] you
oh my god collider has been the [ __ ]
always and thank you so much for
continuing your support man oh please um
seriously i hope it's a huge hit and
anything i can do to help i definitely
will you guys have a great time
thank you
later